ماذا قصد الرئيس التونسي الاسبق زين
العابدين بن علي عندما نقل اليك عبر صديقه
بانه غادر عنوه اذا صح التعبير بانه لم
يختر ان يغادر بنفسه هل اجبر على ذلك اذا
لم يوضح لصديقه استعمل انه لم يغادر من
تلقائي نفسه يعني انه لم
يتخذ القرار اليوم ليغادر كيف غادر الله
اعلم هنالك روايات وانا لا اصدق روايه
ليست امامي مدعمتها الحقيقيه
من يوم الخميس 13 وبالتالي بقاء كل
الوزراء هو بقاء لمواصله الاشغال اليوميه
فقط
وفي انتظار ان تتكون حكومه جديده
ليله طرابلسي زوجه الرئيس او ارمله الرئيس
الان كانت غمزه من قناه علي السوريات مدير
امن الرئاسي بانه هو الذي دفعه الى
المغادره بعد تخويفه من ان المظاهرات
قادمه وان قد يتم ما لا يحمد عقبه
اتهم الجميع في ذلك كل من كان لاصيله
الشان الامني والامن الرئاسي الى اخره
واتهموا بعضهم البعض ولذلك لا يمكن ان
نقول ان فلانا او فلتان لكن المهم هو ان
تلك المغادره جاءت في في في
اخر مسار
طويل هو مسار بينام سمي انا ذاك في بدايه
العشريه بالشرق الاوسط الكبير والتغيرات
الى اخره
حتى وانطلق شان من تونس وكانت الباقيه كما
يقولوا لك قصر من من اوراق اللعب
اقول ابدا انها كانت الثوره ولكن قلت
دائما انها مسيره احتجاجات شعبيه كانت
وراءها اوضاع ومطالب شرعيه لشباب بالجهات
الى اخره
لكن ان نقول انها ثوره يجب ان نرى من هي
قيادتها ما هو برنامجها من وراء الى اخره
ولكن تلك الاحتجاجات وخصوصا بعد خروج
الرئيس من علي
فتحت المكان لكل من كان
يترصد ويتربس بالسلطه واخذوه
وسو عيدوا على ذلك من اطراف مختلفه
اوروبا هنالك من جاء من تحت جبه بريطانيا
هنالك من جاء يعني اللي هي حادثه
ورايين كيف ان عشريه كامله بعد ذلك لم تكن
عسيريه التجديد الحكم بل كانت عشريه
ابتساما للغنم